e a cirurgia de revascularização do
miocárdio ou CRM é realizada para
melhorar a circulação do músculo
cardíaco em pessoas com doença de
artéria coronária Severa neste
procedimento é ligada ou enxertada uma
artéria ou veia saudável de outras
partes do corpo na artéria coronária
obstruída
artéria ou veia enxertada ignora o
bloqueio de uma artéria coronária que
transporta o sangue oxigenado para o
músculo cardíaco é possível fazer a
ponte de uma ou mais artérias coronárias
em uma única operação antes da cirurgia
um tubo intravenoso será colocado e
possivelmente administrada a uma
medicação para lhe ajudar a relaxar os
procedimentos de revascularização do
miocárdio São realizadas com anestesia
geral por isso estará dormindo durante a
operação um tubo de respiração será
inserido através da boca e em sua
garganta para auxiliar a respiração
durante a cirurgia um cateter será
colocado em sua bexiga bom para urina
para cirurgia de revascularização
geralmente leva de 3 a 6 horas em uma
cirurgia convencional o cirurgião
primeiro faz uma incisão na pele sobre o
osso do peito ou externo o cirurgião
cortar ao externo e mover a caixa
torácica para chegar ao coração durante
todo o processo que o sistema
circulatório será conectado a uma bomba
de circulação extracorpórea ou uma
máquina de desvio cardiopulmonar durante
a cirurgia esta máquina executa
temporariamente as funções do coração e
pulmões permitindo parar seu coração
para que o cirurgião possa suturar o
enxerto no local para os enxertos
geralmente é usado um desses dois vasos
sanguíneos artéria torácica interna do
tórax ou a veia safena da perna para
encher toda a artéria torácica interna o
cirurgião deixar a extremidade superior
conectada artéria subclávia E desde
Gerais extremidade inferior da parede
torácica até a artéria coronária um e da
obstrução em seguida o cirurgião
costurar o enxerto no local para
enxertos de veia safena o cirurgião
costurar a uma extremidade para a horta
e outra extremidade artéria estreitada
um pouco além da obstrução com enxertos
firmemente no lugar o cirurgião usar a
sinais elétricos para restaurar o
batimento cardíaco e temporariamente e
colocar a um marca-passo no coração
assim que o coração retoma o ritmo
normal a máquina cardiopulmonar é
desligada o cirurgião unirá o externo
confio especial para cirurgia e suturar
a incisão na pele para fechar um tubo de
drenagem será colocado temporariamente
através da pele abaixo da incisão dos
outros tipos de procedimentos de
revascularização do miocárdio foram
recentemente desenvolvidos à cirurgia de
revascularização sem bomba e a cirurgia
de revascularização
minimamente invasiva a revascularização
coronariana sem bomba é também chamada
de a revascularização do coração batendo
porque o coração não é interrompido e
não é utilizada a máquina cardiopulmonar
em vez disso eu usado um dispositivo
mecânico para estabilizar a parte do
coração onde está sendo realizado o
enxerto os cirurgiões realizam
procedimentos de revascularização
minimamente invasivos utilizando
instrumentos especificamente desenhados
que são inseridos através de pequenas
incisões ou portas no tórax este os
procedimentos às vezes requerem o uso de
uma máquina cardiopulmonar após a
cirurgia você será levado para a unidade
de terapia intensiva a atividade do seu
coração será cuidadosamente monitorada
se necessário os eletrodos de
marca-passo serão usados temporariamente
para controlar sua frequência cardíaca o
dreno de tórax permaneceram no local
para drenar o excesso de sangue EA da
cavidade torácica assim que você
respirar por conta própria o tubo de
respiração será retirado e substituído a
máscara de oxigênio a sonda vesical
permanecerá no lugar a medida em que
você se recupera Durante os próximos
três a quatro dias gradualmente a todos
os dispositivos serão removidos